how are you doing today sir
good stephen how are you doing
i'm doing excellent um let me start by
saying i've seen all of season two uh
it's what i call very good um and i
can't wait to talk about it further with
more people
i'm very happy to hear that uh i'm glad
that it's very good
yeah it's i want to stress very good and
you have a
really uh a really good arc this season
i'm i'm very curious uh you guys were
obviously filming right before kovitz
shut down the world and i read that the
story was you know the scripts were
redone to sort of take in the covet of
it all i'm curious how much of your
storyline maybe got changed as a result
of covid or was it
what it ended up being
when we started the first uh when we
started filming the second season the
first couple of weeks
i was only privy to the first episode or
two so i had a general idea from carrie
about how she saw it going on but much
like
season one they were hesitant to
cement anything in in stone um
because they
part of the task for the writers on this
job is to hit a moving target and to
to
provide episodes of narrative television
that keep up to speed with what's
currently happening which is a very very
difficult thing to do so consequently i
didn't know how far uh they were going
to go
in cory's arc with certain um uh story
lines
that being said
the introduction of covid uh to the
story was so arresting and formidable
that uh i don't think there was anybody
that read it that wasn't ready to try to
undertake it it was a different thing
entirely once we started acting it
because
it hard to go back into the
the moment where you didn't know because
your life had been so populated for the
previous year and a half with everything
you do know all the time so it was uh
it
it felt like in the making of it we're
like oh gosh i don't even know if i can
realistically go back to the point where
i
didn't know about these things you know
i did like i didn't carry that level of
tension with every interaction and uh
that was probably the best acting of the
uh en entire thing
uh do you view corey as a good person
a bad person or does it depend on the
day of the week
that's good
oh i hate to be such a relativist but
it would really depend on the vantage
point with how you judge good and bad
um
living in a capitalist democracy one is
inclined to believe that uh if you
ascend to a role of power or a sense of
wealth then you you must somehow be good
if that's what our
our society is uh if those are the
foundations of our society but i think
most of us uh
generally
are dubious about that idea
i think corey is somebody who navigates
that system
really well
so
can somebody who navigates a system that
may be corrupt
uh very well be without corruption
themselves i
seems unlikely to me but i think like
the rest of the morning show what they
where they find drama
is in the gray areas of all of our lives
we're so interested right now in
creating these polemics
that uh it
has the potential of
of undermining somebody's entire
humanity and so i think the one of the
things that they're they're trying to
explore is what if people aren't good or
bad what if they are sometimes good and
sometimes bad and all in all human
trying to make their way through their
lives as best they can uh i agree with
uh i agree with what you just said um
uh what uh for for people i guess i
wanna know a little generic thing but
what do you wanna tease fans of the show
about season two
oh that's such a great question
making room for the future is not so
easy
and not everybody is
able to navigate the bright new world
and
some people will fall by the wayside
that's very good you have some fantastic
scenes with reese and jennifer this
season um where there's just a lot of
emotions on display uh can you sort of
talk about working with both of them and
what you love about working with both of
them especially in emotional scenes like
that
yeah
well they're both
to arrive at this point in our lives and
our careers
you have to have had a breadth of
experience that
i i find remarkable having tried to
navigate a career and acting myself that
i have um
just
unending affection and
um awe for the people who
have been working in high pressure
situations put themselves in high
pressure situations to try to deliver
complex material
or at the very least um
uh material that appeals to a wide group
of people um
it's really hard
i can express how hard that is to do
so
you immediately feel a sense of
um
uh camaraderie that you get to be a part
of
their world momentarily you know in the
in the scenes of getting to act with
them and they're actually playing people
not unlike themselves who have ascended
to roles of power and um
and are doing their best to navigate
that on a day-by-day basis so it's not
hard uh
in in that way for corey to be very
present in those moments with them and
so there are two things that are
happening one corey is watching them
trying to
understand and predict how their
behavior is going to
uh shape
his own agenda or perhaps
um how he can accommodate it in his
emotional life and then there is my
experience of just uh being at this
point in my career getting to
work with such formidable people on such
uh formidable uh material that uh it
that fills me with a a kind of gratitude
as well
thank you so much for your time and
congrats on that emmy for season one
thanks very much steven i appreciate
that